we don't know what the future will hold
if we're going to have a second wave of
covid
we're adapting one thing we don't want
to do is stop exercising training in
your local neighborhood this is the
future
it's here the coronavirus pandemic has
changed how we live
how we work and how we keep fit but as
commuters started to work from home
financial centers emptied we're going to
have a look at the gym industry in
london new york and hong kong
to see how it can survive
[Music]
at the start of the year the fitness
industry was thriving
but analysts say uk gym memberships have
fallen by almost 20
this year according to ibis world the
market capitalization of the uk's
combined health and fitness sector
has plummeted by 28
revenue generated by the uk gym and
fitness industry meanwhile could also
fall by 28
nuffield health has 110 gyms across the
uk
i've been a member of its city of london
branch for over a decade
but like many former office workers i've
been working from home for most of the
year
so i decided to freeze my membership and
instead i've been working out from home
quite a lot has changed since i was last
here in early march infection prevention
starts here
at the front door the first thing you
notice is the reception staff
who greet you from behind your
protective face visor
before you can enter the building you
have to sanitize your hands and confirm
you don't have any covert symptoms
members are then instructed to swipe in
so the gym can provide the test and
trace service
equipment's still shared but members are
encouraged to disinfect as they go
workout stations are clearly segregated
to allow for social distancing
not that it's needed this place is dead
the financial impact has been
so significant and you've seen it
globally we haven't taken any
revenue from our existing customers for
five months
and also in that time not had any
acquisition of new customers
we had 20 percent of our membership
decided it wasn't right for them to come
back when we reopened
percent of nothing sites are in town
centre locations and we have seen a
decline in usage in those as less people
have come back to work
we've seen many members from clubs like
this one in the city of london
utilizing many of these sites out
perhaps where they live
and where they're commuting from it's
been a particularly tough time for
personal trainers who rely on regular
clients to top up their wages
some clients have opted for virtual
personal training others are staying
away
it's coming up for six o'clock uh on a
wednesday afternoon
in normal times it would be pretty busy
in here wouldn't it we are pretty much
the only people in this space
at least half of the clients cancel
their services
so it's tough it's hard for us but for
those people who are coming in
what's the feedback been like i mean it
must be like having your own private gym
yeah that's what i keep saying to our
members
enjoy while you can for those city
center gym operators that don't have
enough fields medical centers or local
branches to fall back on
things are even tougher the biggest
issue is uncertainty
will there be another full scale
lockdown when gyms close the first time
operators dug deep into their reserves
and whilst
most of the major players have survived
for now i think it's questionable how
well they would fare if they had to
close for a second time
coronavirus has also wiped out the
so-called sleeper members
these are the people who continue to pay
a monthly membership fee despite rarely
using the gym
people cancelled their direct debits for
stuff they
didn't really need sleeper membership in
2019
was 20 of the total membership for the
fitness facility
or gym industry in the uk so again it's
going to take a while
to regain that market share that they
once had
it's a similar story in new york city
gym operators were forced to close in
march and have only just been allowed to
reopen
with reduced capacity while members have
to wear masks while working out
but a crisis can present opportunity
bikelin is an indoor cycling studio like
all gyms we closed in march
we wrote to our members and said stick
with us
help us out we're a small business we're
going to keep our staff
70 members stayed with us but it wasn't
just one month
it was six months and it was those 70
members
that continued to pay their memberships
all through covid
that kept us alive it was that loyal
community of local riders that enabled
bikeland to pivot quickly
it's now the only outdoor spin studio in
new york city we're getting
lots of new people every day probably
60 percent are new people that are
coming from all over new york city
we reached out to instructors from all
over not just our bench of instructors
but from studios all over the city that
are closed they're coming to check it
out we're new yorkers
we like to be together we like to work
out together
it's what we're used to i've lived
through hurricane sandy
i've lived through 9 11 i've seen new
york come and go
on several occasions and what i've
learned
is don't ever bet against new york might
take a little time
it's not going to be easy but we're
coming back
in hong kong gyms have been forced to
close twice
since the start of the pandemic and have
only recently reopened
meanwhile people are flocking to the
coast to play beach tennis
beach volleyball and they're taking to
the seas on stand-up paddleboards
we have a nice offer of certain products
that people really needed
in this crisis and in this time of kovid
just like fitness equipment for example
kayak
beach gear we've been i would say pretty
successful
in this crisis and it has played in our
favor in in a way
maximilian lie is a personal trainer who
runs boot camp style
outdoor training classes social
distancing measures
meant he had to cut the number of people
in his classes
from 40 to just three he adapted his
business
charging more and introducing the use of
weights and resistance bands
but hong kong summers are hot and humid
and training outdoors
isn't for everyone working outdoor is a
very niche market
they don't mind you know no shower they
don't mind the heat
yes with covet people learn that okay
there are substitutions
but when their first choice become
available
i'm pretty sure they will go back to it
it's not the end of gyms
i think we're seeing a shift some people
will not go back
others will definitely gyms have to
face a new challenge in how they
communicate their safety standards
but since the announcement of the gym
reopening again we have seen a slight
drop in sales
so it's definitely not the end people
will go back to it
while gyms in the city of london are
quiet fitness studios in more
residential areas have attracted former
office workers
we've seen an uptick in people that were
working in the city beforehand and are
now
either working two days a week in the
city or working at home and are looking
for
something to fill the gap until they
return people aren't sure
if they're going to be returning to the
office um full time or when that's when
that's going to happen
it's pretty clear looking around the
capacity is being cut
considerably you've got these kind of
workout zones here
i imagine there were many more people
training in the old world
can you sustain this approach for a long
period of time or
do you need the regulations to loosen to
survive
we're running classes currently um with
boxes with 15 boxes
and prior to lockdown our classes were
27 to 36 capacity so obviously that's a
huge
a huge draw it's not ideal but it is
sustainable
we've seen about a 75 return
to normal august it was actually a
better month than we expected
uh but we turned a small profit which
that's great which we weren't we weren't
we weren't expecting 20 seconds changed
the weight
we don't know if there's going to be
another lockdown if that does happen we
are
able to pivot quickly so if we have to
go back to the zoom sessions that's
that's what we'll do
is the idea of training locally rather
than near where you would have worked
something that you're going to stick
with oh yeah definitely yeah
yeah i'm not competing back to victoria
anytime soon even started taking up
cycling like we don't even
have public transport anymore got a
basket
investors should be concerned about the
gym industry
coronavirus has increased the external
competition you've got the likes of
peloton
and large organizations actually see an
opportunity
such as apple external competition from
the likes of
zoom workouts or instagram live workouts
personalities online have really
established a profile
and gained a following we know that
offering a digital product alongside a
bricks and mortar membership
positively influences members to return
to their gym
so savvy operators need to be offering a
hybrid product combining
on-demand content with physical access
they want to continue to be current and
relevant to their members too
due to flexible working patterns and no
longer doing all their exercise within
the four walls of the gym
it's hard to predict whether there will
be more lockdowns for how long people
will be working and training from home
or if gyms will again be forced to shut
their doors some people remain reluctant
to return to indoor training
preferring instead to exercise in the
open air those fitness businesses that
adapt and pivot quickly
and provide a space where people feel
safe at least have a fighting chance